Ben Güzel BCK 9. sınıf oyuncum Jorfa
Gundan YouTube'un en büyük Jorf kanalına
hepiniz hoş geldiniz. Zedua öğretmenleri
ile beraber yaptığımız 9. sınıf okula
deste kampımızın bugün geldik 21.
gününe. Bugün nüfus politikalarını
öğreneceğiz sizinle beraber. Çok
zorlayıcı bir konu değil gençler. Sadece
yorum yapmayı gerektiren bir konu.
Beşeri coğrafya konusu olduğu için
genelde bunlar yorum yaparak
yapabildiğimiz konular.
Zorlanmayacaksanız merak etmeyin. Ne
diyoruz o zaman? Yunus hocayla bir defa
öğren. Bir daha asla unutma. Zedua ile
eğitim her yerde. Geldik nüfus
politikaları da gençler bakın bu konu
basit bir konu. Sadece ben sana bak
şurayı böyle yorumluyorsun. Burayı böyle
yorumluyorsun dediğimde böyle dikkatli
bir şekilde dinle. Nasıl yorumlayacağını
öğren. Orada sana yorumlama kısmında
verdiğin bilgileri ezberleme. Ha bundan
bundan dolayı şöyle oluyormuş diye yorum
kısmını öğrenirsen hiç sorun yaşamazsın.
Bak konunun ismine dikkat et. Nüfus
politikaları. He demek ki ülkelerin
çeşitli çeşitli politikaları oluyor. Bu
arada zeduva.com sitesinden gençler bu
PDF'i böyle renkli bir şekilde indirip
kullanabilirsiniz. Net nasıl hocam
ülkelerin nüfus politikaları olabilir?
Neden farklılık gösterir? Şimdi gençler
dikkat edin. Her ülkenin nüfus miktarı
aynı mı? Hayır. Her ülkenin doğal
kaynağı aynı mı? Hayır. E her ülkenin
gelişmişliği aynı mı? Hayır. E dikkat
edin şimdi bir ülkede nüfusun çok hızlı
arttığını düşünün. Çok hızlı artıyor
nüfus ya. çok hızlı artıyor. Öyle böyle
değil. Ama o ülkenin doğal kaynakları
sınırlı ve kalkınma hızı. Yani ülke öyle
hızlı kalkınamıyor. Kalkınma hızı da
düşük. E ne yapacağım ben şimdi? Ama
ülke durmadan artıyor. E kalkınma hızım,
doğal kaynağım, param yok. O zaman bak
burada bir sorun ortaya çıkar. Ülke bu
sefer bakamaz buradaki insanlara. Bu
sefer der ki ya ben bunları bu kadar
artıyoruz bu artış hızını yavaşlatayım
bu kadar hızlı artmasın der. Bakın bir
politika geliştirmek zorunda kalır. Ya
da bir ülke var Almanya mesela.
Almanya'da bu sefer doğal kaynak var.
Kalkınma hızı yüksek. Asıl orada önemli
olan bu. Kalkınma hızı yüksek. İş var,
her şey var, para var ama nüfus yok. Bu
sefer de ben bu fabrikalarda
çalıştıracağım insanı bulamıyorum. Çünkü
kalkınma hızım yüksek. Nüfus o kadar
hızlı gelmiyor peşinden. Bu sefer ortada
açık çıkıyor. Bu sefer de Almanya ne
diyecek? Çeşitli politikalar
uygulayacak. Ya nüfusunu arttırmaya
çalışacak, kalkınma hızıyla aynı
seviyeye çıkartmaya çalışacak. E bunu
yapamıyorsa da diyecek ki hım böyle
olmaz dışarıdan nüfus alayım, göç alayım
diyecek. Farklı politikalar
geliştirecek. İşte nüfus politikaları
böyle ortaya çıkıyor. Bakın neden ortaya
çıkıyor nüfus politikaları? Nüfus artış
hızı ile alakalı. Bunları ezberlemene
gerek yok. Mantıken düşün. Nüfus artış
hızı fazlaysa, azsa bu benim politikamı
belirleyebiliyormuş. Demek ki bir
ülkedeki sosyal, ekonomik, siyasi yapı
bunu belirliyor. Doğal kaynak, ekonomi,
kalkınma hızı. Aslında az önce sana bir
giriş yaptım ya. O girişte söylediğim
şeyler bunlar. Dikkat edersen sana ne
dedim? Kalkınma hızı dedim. Değil mi?
Böyle örnek verdim. Buradaki doğal
kaynaklar dedim. O ülkenin parası,
ekonomisi dedim. Artış hızı dedim. Bazen
hızlı artıyor ülkeler. Bazen yavaş
artıyor. İşte bütün bunlar şu gördüğünüz
maddeleri topladığınızda ülkeler bu
özelliklerine göre nüfus politikası
belirliyor. Peki hocam ülkeler bu
özelliklerine göre nasıl nüfus
politikaları belirliyor? O kısma
gelelim. Bu özelliklerimize göre bir
tane nüfus artış hızını azaltmaya
yönelik politika izleyen ülkeler ortaya
çıkabiliyor. Ne demek bu? Bir ülke
düşüneceksin. Bak nüfus artış hızını
azaltma. Somutlamak için eksi yazıyorum.
Nüfus artış hızını azaltacağım ben.
Hangi ülke nüfus artış hızını azaltmaya
çalışır ki? Bir düşün. He nüfus artışım
burada, kalkınma hızım burada. Bak e
kalkınma hızım çok az. Ekonomim yavaş
gidiyor. Ben bu ekonomiyle, bu kalkınma
hızıyla nüfus artışımın yüksek olduğu bu
nüfus artışını nüfusu besleyemiyorum.
Gelişmemiş bir ülkeyim demek ki. Ben
gelişmemiş bir ülke olduğum için nüfus
artış hızım fazla. Bu nüfus artış hızını
düşürmem gerekiyor. Örnek bakın
Bangladeş, Hindistan, Nijerya, Pakistan,
Endonezya. Sana böyle bir soru
sorulduğunda hemen somutlayacaksın.
Nüfus artış hızını azaltmaya çalışın.
Çalışan dediğinde kim azaltmaya çalışır?
He, nüfus artış hızı çok yüksek. Bunlar
durmadan çocuk yapıyorlar diyeceksin. Ha
Somali gibi ülkeler diyeceksin. Ben sana
ne demiştim? Gelişmemiş ülke düşüneceğin
zaman ben Somali'yi düşünüyorum. Sen de
buradan Pakistan'ı seç mesela.
Bangladeş'i seç. Tamam. Ama somutlayacak
bir ülken olsun. Somali. Nüfus artış
hızını Somali ne yapmaya çalışır?
Azaltmaya çalışır. Neden? Şuradaki
terimi kullanıyor sorularda. O yüzden
bunun üzerinden öğren bunu. Bak ne
diyor. Nüfus artış hızının kalkınma
hızından yüksek olduğu. Ne demek? Nüfus
kalkınma hızım burada. Nüfus artış hızı
burada. Kalkınmadan daha fazla nüfus
var. O zaman bu ülke gelişmemiş ülke.
Somali gibi ülkeler bunu yapıyor. Demek
ki ne yapıyorlar? Nüfus artış hızını
azaltmaya çalışıyorlar ki kalkınma hızı
burada, nüfus artış hızı burada. Nüfus
artış hızını kalkınmayla aynı seviyeye
getirirsek ancak bakabiliriz biz bu
ülkedeki insanlara diyorlar. Neden bunu
azaltmak istiyorlar? Çünkü gençler
kalkınma hızı buradaysa nüfus da çok
hızlı artıyorsa o zaman doğal kaynaklar
aşırı tükenecek. Çok hızlı tükenecek
doğal kaynaklar. E yetersiz beslenecek
insanlar. Buralar gelişmemiş ülke.
İnsanlar yetersiz besleniyor.
Yetemiyoruz bu parayla bu insana
bakamıyoruz. Yetersiz beslenme ortaya
çıkıyor. Konutlar yetmiyor. Konut açığı
ortaya çıkıyor. Konutların fiyatları
alıp başını gidiyor. İşsizlik ortaya
çıkıyor. İnsanlar gidiyorlar
gecekondulaşma, çarpın ketleşme
yapıyorlar. Bir sürü sorun ortaya
çıkıyor. O yüzden ülke diyor nüfus artış
hızını düşürelim. Anlaştık mı? Gelelim
şu tarafa. Ve bakın piramide. Şu ülke
dikkat edin bakın gelişmemiş. Görüyor
musunuz? Şöyle doğumların fazla olduğu
şu altı görmeyin. Tamam bu altı
görmeyin. Şu piramide bir bakın. Şu
piramide gelişmemiş ülke piramidi
görüyor musunuz? Sonra bu ülke diyor ki
benim doğumları azaltmam lazım. Nüfus
artış hızını düşürmem lazım. Bu sefer de
asimetrik piramide dönüyor. Bakın nüfus
artış hızını düşürmeye başlıyor.
Gördünüz mü? Son yıllarda nüfus artış
hızını azaltmaya çalışan, politika
izleyen ülkenin piramidi. İşte bu. Demek
ki ben ülke politikası olarak bir neyi
gördüm? Şimdi nüfus artış hızını
azaltıcı yönde politika izleyen ülkeleri
gördüm. Başka nasıl politika izler
ülkeler nüfus politikası olarak? Bu
sefer nüfus artış hızını arttırmak
isteyeceğim. artı koyacağım somutlamak
için. Bir de buna bir ülke bulalım. Kim
nüfus artış hızını arttırmak ister?
Nüfusunu kim arttırmak ister? Mesela
Hindistan. Düşün ya Hindistan zaten çok
kalabalık bir ülke. Neden nüfus artış
hızını arttırsın ki? Çok saçma geliyor
değil mi? Zaten orada ekonomik olarak
besleyemiyorsun ki ülkeleri, insanları.
Pardon. O zaman kim arttırmak ister?
Mantıken düşün. Hemen düşüneceksin.
Somali. Somali olur mu? Ha hocam
Somali'de insanlar çok fazla çocuk
yapıyorlar. Ekonomi burada. E o zaman
olmaz ki. Besleyemiyorum. O zaman Somali
de olmaz. Örnek verelim. Ters örnek
verelim bu sefer. Almanya diyelim. He
bakalım hemen somutlayalım. Bunlar
üzerinden yorum yapacağız. Almanya. He
Almanya'da kalkınma seviyesi burada.
Tepede ekonomik kalkınma seviyesi
burada. İş imkanları burada. Nüfus.
Nüfus o kadar çocuk yapmıyor Almanlar.
Nüfus burada. Ha burada bir problem var
diyeceksin. Çünkü kalkınma, ekonomi,
sanayi burada çalışacak insan lazım.
Çalışacak insan yok. Nüfus artış hızı
düşük. O zaman kim? Almanya gibi
gelişmiş ülkeler nüfus artış hızını
yükseltmeye çalışır. Neden? Kalkınma
seviyesiyle aynı seviyeye çıkartmak
için. Böylece sanayide çalıştıracak
insan bulur. Böylece ekonomiden, ekonomi
var zaten, para var. Dinamik bir nüfus
elde eder yukarıya çekerse. Yani nüfus
artışısını kim arttırmaya çalışıyor?
Almanya gibi gelişmiş ülkeler. Sana soru
sorulduğunda kim nüfus artış hızını
arttırmak ister? Örnek ver. Neden
arttırmak ister? Bunu yorumla diye
sorar. Tamam. Biz de yorumluyoruz. Neden
nüfus artış hızını arttırmak istiyor
Almanya? Çünkü gençler şimdi nüfus artış
hızı yavaş. Çocuk doğmuyor. E çocuk
doğmuyor. Almanya gibi ülkelerde nüfus
öyle artmıyor. Çocuk yok. Herkes
yaşlanıyor. E bak yaşlı nüfus arttığı
için başka az önce söylediğim iş gücü
bulamıyoruz. Çalışacak çocuk yok.
Çalışacak çocuk diyorum ya. Çalışacak
insan bulamıyoruz. Ülke yaşlanmış. Ülke
dinamizmini kaybetmiş. Hareketliliğini.
Bunları kim yapıyor? Almanya, Japonya,
İsveç gibi gelişmiş ülkeler. Peki bu
ülkenin piramidinde nasıl bir değişim
olur? Bakın bu ülkenin piramidine dikkat
edin. Şu kısımlar artık doğumların iyice
azaldığı kısımlar. Görüyor musunuz?
Doğumlar azalmış. Ama son yıllarda bakın
ülke politika izleyerek, nüfusu
arttırıcı yönde politika izleyerek
doğumları ne yapmaya başlamış?
Arttırmaya başlamış diyeceksin. Evet bu
yorumu da böyle. Peki nasıl nüfusu
arttırabilirim ki ben hocam? Nüfus artış
hızısını nasıl arttırabilirim? Şöyle
bakın. Doğumları teşvik ederek. Ülkeler
doğumları teşvik eder gençler. Nasıl?
Çocuk başına maddi yardımı arttırarak.
Almanya'da böyle hatırlayın Kemal
Snow'un filmlerinde vardı. Almanya'ya
gidiyordu. Orada 56 tane çocuk
yapıyordu. Her çocuk için para alıyordu.
Dünya kadar parayı topluyordu. Evet.
İnsanlar, ülkeler insanlara para
veriyor. Maddi yardım yapıyor.
Vergilerden muaf tutuyor. Diyor ki işte
ü tane çocuğun varsa sana vergilerden
muaf tutacağız seni. Bu da nüfus artış
hızını arttıracak yönde politikalar.
Tamam. Evet. Şu ülke ÖSYM sorusu olduğu
için ben çözmüyorum. Örnek 7. Cevap
cevap şu diye yorumlara belirtiyorsunuz.
Bakalım çözebilecek misiniz? Çıkmış soru
bu. Tamam. Gelelim buraya şu kısma.
Gençler bazı ülkeler zamanında
arttırmaya yönelik politika izlerken
sonra bunu da değiştirebilir. Bunu
unutmayın. İlla arttıracağız diye bir
şey yok. Az sonra Türkiye'de göreceğiz.
Bir dönem arttırmışız, bir dönem
azaltmışız. Azaltmaya çalışmışız. Şimdi
tekrar arttırmaya çalışıyoruz. Bu dönem
dönem değişen bir şey. Tamam. Başka
hocam başka politika izler mi ülkeler?
Şu ana kadar hangi politikayı gördük?
nüfusu azaltıcı yönde politika izliyordu
bazı ülkeler. Bazı ülkeler nüfusu
arttırmaya çalışıyordu. Bazı ülkelerde
nüfusun ülke içindeki dağılışını
düzenlemeye çalışır. Bu da bir nüfus
politikasıdır. Mesela ülkemizde gençler
16 milyon resmi rakamlara göre gayrimi
rakamlarda 20 milyona yaklaşabiliyor.
İstanbul'un nüfusu. Batıyı, Batı işte
İzmir'i, Ankara'yı, Bursa'yı vesaire
düşündüğünüzde insanların çoğu
Türkiye'de batıya yığılmış durumda.
Bakın düzensiz bir nüfus dağılı. E
doğuda, Güneydoğu'da, doğuda, Karadeniz
kısmında o kadar değerli arazilerimiz
var. İnsanların buralara da yayılması
lazım. Ülke içerisinde nüfusun dengeli
dağılması lazım. Böyle politikalarda
izliyor ülkeler. Bunu özellikle Kanada,
Endonezya, Avustralya, Norveç, Çin,
Hindistan gibi ülkeler yapıyorlar.
Türkiye de aslında bunu yapmaya
çalışıyor. Kalkınma, kalkınma
projelerimiz var bizim onlarla. Mesela
GAP projesi bunlardan bir tanesi.
Güneydoğu Anadolu projesi. İnsanlar o
Güneydoğu Anadolu'dan gitmesin. Orada
insanlar dengeli dağılsın ülkemizde
diye. Bu ülkelerde de yapılıyor. Bu amaç
ne burada? İnsanların hepsinin büyük
şehirlerde ve bir merkezde toplanmaması.
ülkenin geneline yayılarak dengeli bir
dağılış sergilemesi. Tamam. Bu da
politikalardan bir tanesi. Ülkelerin
politikalarından neymiş? Ülke içinde
nüfusun düzenli dağılması. Bir tane daha
politika var. Demografik yapıyı
iyileştirme. Ne demek demografik?
Demografi neydi? Nüfus bilimiydi.
Nüfusun eğitimini, sağlık imkanlarını
daha yani böyle kaliteli bir nüfus
ortaya çıkartmak için böyle politika
izleniyor bazı ülkelerde de. Yani ülke
diyor ki ya benim nüfusumu arttırmama
gerek yok. Nüfusumu azaltmama da gerek
yok. Benim nüfusum dengeli. Ülke içinde
de dengeli dağılıyor. Artışı da azalışı
da dengeli. E dengedeyse diyor ki ben bu
ülkemin arttırmayı azaltmaya
çalışmayayım. Bu ülkemin eğitimini,
nüfusun eğitimini, sağlık imkanlarını
bunları düzenli bir şekilde yapayım
diyor. İşte bu da demografik yapıyı
iyileştirme politikası oluyor. Anlaştık
mı? Bunu niye yapıyoruz? eğitim
seviyesini yükseltmek için işte bak iş
imkanları sağlamak, istihdam için,
beslenme koşulları için, sağlık
koşulları için yani kaliteli bir yaşam
için böyle politika izleniyor bazı
ülkelerde. Bu da bizim 4üncü
politikamızdı. Geliyoruz 5.
politikamıza. Bazı ülkelerde göç
politikası belirliyorlar. Nasıl? Almanya
mesela bunların başında Katar, ABD,
Kanada. Kanada'da da var değil mi? Bunu
biliyoruz. Mesela ülkemizden insanların
daha çok nereye gittiğini görüyorsunuz.
Almanya ve Kanada'ya gidiyor insanlar.
Neden? Çünkü Almanya, Kanada gibi
ülkeler gelişmiş ülkeler. Para var,
sanayi var, çalışacak yer var ama insan
yok ortada. Bu iş alanlarında üretken,
çalışan, aktif, dinamik bir nüfus yok. O
zaman ne yapıyor bu ülkeler? Dışarıdan
göç alıyorlar. Tabii ki bunu kriterilere
göre, öyle herkes gelsin değil. Bunu
belirli kriterlerde işte ilana da
çıkıyorlar. şu alanlarda insanları
alacağız diye. Eğitimi yüksek, kendini
geliştirmiş, dil bilen insanları
ülkelerine alıyorlar. Bu da göç. Evet.
Göç politikasıyla ülkelerin nüfus
politikasının belirlenmesi. Demek ki beş
tane politika öğrendik sizinle. Ne? bir
nüfusu azaltmaya çalışan ülkeler bunlar
gelişmemişti Somali gibi nüfusu
arttırmaya çalışan ülkeler Almanya gibi
gelişmiş ülkelerdi. Bir de nüfusun
demografik yapısını iyileştirmeye
çalışan, sağlığını, eğitimini
iyileştirmeye çalışan politikalar vardı.
Bir de göç politikası vardı. Göç alarak
nüfusta denge kurmaya çalışan, çalışan,
nüfus belirlemeye çalışan politikalar
vardı. Bir de şuradaki nüfusun ülke
içerisindeki dağılış politikamız vardı.
5 1 2 3 4 5 tane politika. Tamam. Bu
politikalar var. Bunları gördük. Bir
tane daha sorumuz var burada. ÖSYM
sorusu olduğu için yine size
bırakıyorum. Örnek 8. Cevap şu diye
çözüyorsunuz. Gelelim şimdi Türkiye'deki
nüfus politikalarına. Gençler bakın ne
gördük az önce. Ülkelerin nüfus
politikaları var dedik. Peki ülkemizin
nüfus politikası ne? Bu yıllara göre
değişkenlik gösteriyor. Geçmişten
günümüze doğru bunu ezberlemenize gerek
yok. Mesela ülkemiz kurulduğunda 1923
yıllarında bakın şu devrede gençler şu
devrede ülkemiz nasıl yeni kurulmuş.
Savaştan çıkmışız. 12 13 milyona yakın
insan var. Savaştan çıkmışız.
Savaşlardan çıkmışız. Çalışacak insan
yok. Savaşta erkeklerin çoğu ölmüş,
vefat etmiş, şehit olmuş. E çalıştıracak
insan yok. Ne yapmışız biliyor musunuz?
nüfusu bu dönemde aynı benim böyle
yaptığım gibi arttırma politikası
izlemişiz. Böyle artı koy oraya. Bu
dönemde nüfusu arttırıcı yönde politika
izlemişiz. İşte çok çocuklu ailelere
madalya vermişiz. Bunu da yapmışız.
Evet. Dışarıdan o Osmanlı Devleti
dağılıp da sadece Türkiye kalınca
dışarıda Türkler kaldı. Mesela
Bulgaristan'da falan. Türklere ülkenize
gelebilirsiniz demişiz. Eee gelenlere
buralarda topraklar vermişiz. Nüfusu
1923. Bu dönemde ne yapmışız? Arttırıcı
yönde politikayız demişiz. Sonra gençler
nüfusumuz artmış ama
196580 yıllarına geldiğimizde bu sefer
işler değişmiş. Bu sefer de nüfus
artışısız çok tavanlara çıkmış. Çok çok
fazla artmış. Bu sefer de şu dönemde
azaltmaya yönelik politika izleyelim
demişiz. Çünkü bu dönemde nüfus hızlı
artmış. Dışarıdan göçler gelmiş. Tarımda
makineleşme artmış. İnsana bu kadar
fazla ihtiyaç olmadığı anlaşılmış
makineler ortaya çıkmış. Bu sefer de
demişiz ki biz bunu azaltmaya yönelik
politikayız diyelim. Bak önce arttırdık
sonra azalttık. Bu sefer
19825 yılları arasında bu sefer de
nüfusun demografik niteliğini
iyileştirmeye yönelik. Buna da ne
diyelim? Yuvarlak diyelim. Buna da şöyle
yani nüfusun sağlığını, eğitimini
iyileştirmeye yönelik bir politika
izlemişiz. Bak arttırdık, azalttık.
Sonra nüfusu iyileştirelim dedik. Sonra
baktık ki bu iş böyle olmayacak.
2005'ten sonra bu sefer tekrar nüfusu az
arttırmaya yönelik politikaya geçtik. Şu
anda içinde bulunduğumuz dönemde nüfusu
arttırmaya çalışıyoruz. Nasıl arttırmaya
çalışıyoruz? Çok çocuklu ailelere ne
yapıyoruz? İşte bir çocuk yaptığında
para veriyoruz. İki çocukta daha fazla.
Üç çocuk da daha fazla. İlk doğumlarda
işte annelere erken emeklilik şansı
tanınıyor. Her çocukta yıl düşüyor
emeklilikte bildiğim kadarıyla. İşte
ücretli izin kısmı arttırılabiliyor.
Dadı yardımı verilebiliyor. Yani böyle
çeşitli süt emzirme saatleri ile alakalı
memurlara yardım tanınıyor. Yani emzirme
saati arttırılabiliyor. Bu şekilde
çocukların artması ve ülkenin
dinamizmini kaybetmenin önüne geçmek
istiyor ülkemiz. Ne demek gençler? Bir
ülkede nüfus ne kadar kalabalıksa o
kadar fazla ticaret döner. O kadar fazla
alver olur. E her alver dinamik hareket
ülkeye vergi kazandırır. Şimdi
düşünsenize 80 milyonluk, 90 milyonluk,
300 milyonluk nüfusa sahip ülkelerde
dönen parayı ve vergiyi bir düşünün. Bir
de ülkemizin 10 milyon olduğunu düşünün.
10 milyon olduğumuzda ne kadar alışveriş
olacak da ülkeye vergi gidecek? Böyle
düşünün. Bizim ülkemizin nüfusundan
dolayı çok fazla vergi, çok fazla
dinamik hareket yaşanıyor. Bu da ülkeyi
ekonomik olarak kalkındırıyor.
Ekonomisini güçlendiriyor. Ama 5
milyonluk bir ülke olsak, 10 milyonluk
bir ülke olsak ne kadar gücümüz olacak
ki? Yani ne kadar para dönecek? O yüzden
ülkeler nüfusunu biz de mesela
nüfusumuzu arttırmaya geçtik. Ülkemiz
çünkü hafif hafif gelecekte yaşlanıyor.
Şu an bile ülkemiz gelecekte daha da çok
yaşlanacağını projeksiyon olarak
öngörüyoruz. O duruma düşmemek için
şimdiden nüfusu arttırmaya yönelik
politikalar izliyoruz. Hatta nüfusu
bakıyoruz ki kendimiz arttıramayacağız.
Dışarıdan ülkeye göç alıyoruz, kapıları
açıyoruz. Sınırlar o kadar şey değil,
kontrollü değil. Ülkeye ne kadar çok
insan gelirse o kadar fazla daha ucuza
insan çalıştırılabilir. Daha çok vergi
alınabilir mantığıyla. Bu da
politikalarımızdan bir tanesi. Ama demek
ki artık son yıllarda nüfusu arttırmaya
çalışıyoruz. Evet. O zaman şu soruyu da
cevaplıyorsunuz. Bakın yine bir ÖSYM
sorusu. Örnek 9, cevap bu diye
cevaplıyorsunuz. Şunu çözdüyseniz e
tamam bakın üniversite sınavında çıkacak
soruyu çözdünüz demektir. Evet nüfus
politikaları konumuz da bu kadardı.
Seviliyorsunuz gençler hızlı bir şekilde
diğer konularınızı da halledeceğim.
Kendinize güzel bakın. Ne diyoruz o
zaman? Yunus hocayla bir defa öğren. Bir
daha asla unutma. Zedua ile eğitim her
yerde.